eloquent peasant it's some sort of  ancient document from all the Egyptian  times it gone  it it's a mystery we like Mysteries  [Music]  what's happening  this character seemed like they're from  The Wizard of Oz so you'll help us find  the wizard and maybe some antacid my  stomach is a little iffy  maybe it's some sort of clue look  I don't want the ghost  please just tell me where I am there's a  ghost he's releasing fictional  characters into our world to help us  solve a mystery if you want to see the  big picture  look at things from a different angle  whoa  how about getting me out of here The  Mouse and the Motorcycle  meet rainbow she can shape-shifted  different people  I'm Wilbur and I'm terrific right  Charlotte we have to hurry we can't give  up it's Brave young people like you  that'll make the world a better place  did you guys finish reading the book  loved it me too  you're spoilers please